لا تزال عمليات الانقاذ مستمره للكثير من
العالقين تحت انقاذ زلزال تركيا وسوريا
المدمر حيث يقبع عدد كبير لم يحدد بعد تحت
الابنيه المتهمه وسط الابلاغ عن مئات
المفقودين العديد من الدول مدت جسور
الانقاذ لتركيا وسوريا اللتين ناشدتا
العالم لاجل المساعده في التخفيف من
الاعباء التي خلفها زلزال السادس من
فبراير الحالي وفي وقت تستمر فيه
المحاولات للعثور على ناجين فقدت سوريا
احد اشهر لاعبيها التاريخيين النجم السابق
نادر جخدار الذي راح ضحيه الزلزال بصحبه
ابنها فيما نعى السوريون من اطلق عليهم
اسم طبيب الفقراء في مدينه جبله الدكتور
فايز عطاف وزوجه الدكتوره هاله سعيد فيما
يستمر البحث في الجانب التركي على اللاعب
الغني المفقود كريستيانو
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعات من وقوع الزلزال خرجت السلطات
في تركيا وفي سوريا بنداءات وخطوات عاجله
مع اولويه واحده انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه في
تركيا اعلنت الحكومه حاله الانذار على
المستوى الرابع وهذا يعني عمليا ان البلاد
تطالب المساعده من الاخرين وبالفعل هب
المنقذون من دول العالم باسره في سوريا
الوضع اكثر تعقيدا فالارض مقسمه في الشمال
بين مناطق سيطره النظام ومناطق سيطره
المعارضه وقلت تلك المناطق التقت في
النكبه دمشق ناشط الدول العالم لمساعدتها
واول المستجبين دول عربيه وحلفاء دمشق في
دول مثل روسيا اما مناطق سيطره المعارضه
فقد اعلنت جهات اغاثيه فيها انها مناطق
منقوبه بشكل كامل بسبب سقوط عشرات الضحايا
فيما لم يتضح بعد اي خطط لانقاذ المتضررين
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى حلب الان معنا من هناك ناشط
الاعلامي رمضان سليمان رمضان اهلا بك معنا
في صباح العربيه ضمن هذه التغطيه اليوم
رمضان الصليب الاحمر الدولي ذكر امس بان
فرق الانقاذ لا تملك المعدات اللازمه
للوصول الى العالقين تحت الانقاذ بالتالي
ما الذي ينقصكم ما هي المعدات اللازمه
للانقاذ بالاساس
الوضع في مدينه جنديرس وضع ماساوي جدا
انستين الوضع في المدينه وريف حلب اذا بقي
يسير على هذه الوتيره ربما نحتاج الاشهر
لازاله الركام والانقاب تحت نحن بحاجه
للتدخل الدولي بشكل عاجل لانقاذ ما تبقى
من الاهالي تحت الركام
طيب يا استاذ رمضان اليوم يعني هل يمكن
لكم انه كافراد عاديين انه تساهموا
بعمليات الانقاذ هل يسمح لكم مثلا
المواطنين اصحاب بنايه ما انه يتجمعوا
يساعدوا في عمليات الانقاذ لزيل الركام
والحطام
انستي الاهالي منذ لحظه وقوع المنازل وهم
يبحثون الامكانيات محدوده جدا الامكانيات
محدوده جدا يحاول بها المدنيين وفرق
الدفاع المدني في رفع الانقاذ والبحث عن
طيب رمضان كان جدا محدوده كيف بتم عمليات
الانقاذ يعني مثلا بتلاقوا بنايه مهدمه
بتعرفوا انه فيها ناس تحتها كيف ببلشوا
ببلشوا في دينهم بحث بالايدين البحث في
القزمه في الشواكيش في المعاول في اي
يسمعون الاصوات يعني انا امبارح شاهد على
هذه على احدى الحالات نسمع صوت الاطفال
وهم ينادون اخرجونا من هنا اخرجونا من هنا
ونحن لا نملك اي معدات ولا نملك اي شيء
قادرين ان نسحب هؤلاء الاطفال انا بعيني
صورته هذاك المشهد الطفل ينادينا انه بدي
كاسه ماء بدي
ساعدوني ان اخرج من هذه الانقاذ نحن لسنا
قادرين عن اخراج اي شخص تحت هذه الانقاب
نحن بحاجه لتدخل دولي سريع يوجد لحد الان
اهالي تحت الانقاض عائشه عايشين يعني احنا
بدنا نقدم لهم وساعات مساعدات نخرجهم لكن
لا جدوى لا جدوى نحن
ضئيله جدا وحتى مصاعب تواجهكم اثناء
عمليات الانقاذ
في جنديرس وحدها يوجد 80 بناء والبناء
[__] على عده شقق منزليه 80 بناء لا يوجد
لدينا يعني كل شخص في بنايات والله لم ما
حدا راح لها ما حدا قدر يصلي البنايات
لانه ما حدا قدران يعمل شيء يعني الطابق
الخامس سقف الطابق الخامس على الارض
والناس كلها تحت في في ناس عائلات بالاكمل
عائلات بالاكمل امبارح انا شاهد على احد
العائلات 12 فرد من عائله واحده
وصورنا الطفله طفله ولدت حديثا امها ماتت
تحت الركام وولدت طبعا المقطع انتشر على
جميع وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي العائله
بالكامل
اخواتها اربعه
ابوها وامها وعمتها بقيت لحالها مولوده
جديده حاليا هي في المشفى الحمد لله
امورها بخير امورها الصحيه في تمام ولكن
لا نستطيع ان نقدم اي شيء لهؤلاء الناس
تحت الركام نحن بحاجه لتدخل دولي نحن
بحاجه
لمعدات
لسحب هؤلاء الناس من تحت الركام وبالتاكيد
ايضا شاهدنا فيديوهات عده مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اب ينادي ابنته وهي تحت الركام
يعني نحن كنا نسمعها ولكن لا نراها على
امل ان تكون ايضا انقذت وتم ايضا انقاذها
من تحت الركام نستطيع الوضع ماساوي جدا
انا بام عيني رايت اب يحمل ابنه يعني
اثنين هم ميتين تحت الركام الاب والابن
زوج وزوجته ماسكين بيدهم الناس نحن هنا
بسبب القصف وبسبب الحرب اللي صارت على على
المناطق السوري الابنيه هي مضعضعه وتعبانه
من دون ما يجينا هذا الزلزال كانت الابنيه
تعبانه وشبه خاليه سبحان الله اتى هذا
الزلزال فلم يبقى حجر على حجر
العائلات بالاكمل وانت تعرفي انه حدث
الساعه الرابعه صباحا فكانت جميع الاهالي
نايمين
مسك ابنه ومات هو وابنه تحت الركام انا
بعرف امبارح شخص واقف على جثث اولاده
عائلته عشره لم يبقى منهم الاب وابنه عم
يبكي ما عرفان انه بنته وبنته يعني اسمها
شام بنته وهو حامله بايده وقعت منه ماتت
يعني
مشاعر لا كلمات تصف ما يحصل الان يعني سوى
اليوم دعوات وايضا التضامن العالمي
والدعوات لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه شكرا لك